So similar to what we saw in the data binding,
we can have D3 objects which exist in our JavaScript scope, but it is not until
we actually choose to select some elements on the page, either HTML or SVG.
And append something to them which has some visual representation that
the actual axis objects themselves get rendered as SVG.
In this case we first select the SVG which contains our chart,
we append a group in this case SVG g-element.
And again you can think of this analogous to a div tag in HTML, simply a way to
group other SVG elements which doesn't have intrinsic visual display itself.
So think of a group in SVG.
As some invisible fence around a bunch of other SVG objects.
We add a class to it.
Actually two classes.
Both class x and class axis.
And then, change the transform attribute on the group
to move everything contained within the group,
zero pixels in the x direction, and height pixels in the y direction.
Since SVG has an inverse coordinate space by translating rg we
move it zero in the x and
height in the y which corresponds to the bottom of our chart in this case.
And for the y-axis we do the same.
This time, instead of giving it the classes, both x and
axis, we give it the class y and axis.
Notice that the axis class is common between the two.
This allows us to apply CSS selectors to both the x and y axis.
But since we also attached a separate x class and a separate y class
we can then further specialize the x and the y styling independently.